[Music]
now
[Music]
i was uh i was too busy watching the
demilio show this week
did you dye your hair black
for the show like to celebrate yeah or
like you know it was like one of those
things where you know like when game of
thrones would happen and people would
put on like old laundry
with a shield and be like
game of thrones like was it like that
would yeah like dye your hair yeah it
was a pretty anticipated premiere for
sure yeah i think for a lot of people
i actually didn't watch it it's crazy
that they have a show on hulu hot take
it's gonna work you think so yeah i know
everyone listening is extremely online
right you're chronically online but most
of the world is not
so they just kind of know her as like
some popular girl from the internet and
then they'll go on hulu and she's like
oh i guess she has her own show and
they'll just start watching and then
they're gonna fall in love with other
aspects like oh their family's so cute
and oh it's so crazy to watch her grow
up and i think it's going to work yeah i
mean i guess people watch
family vlogs and get obsessed with them
and those are so boring yeah nothing
happens now with a little bit of drama
yeah i guess
i was listening to uh tim dillon talk
about it
and he was just like there's nothing
there's no
nothing that you want to see behind the
scenes of tick tock yeah nothing happens
yeah you know you don't watch it tick
tock and you're like wait well how do
they why did they do this what went
through their mind right before they did
this you know he was like i was watching
an old episode of the kardashians the
mom was their manager i had no idea
chris jennings no chris jenner
that's why they called her mommager and
now i get i'm piecing it all together
now but yeah that's real [ __ ] and you
know kris jenner i mean
she's really good at what she does i
mean she got mederna and pfizer popping
what oh she manages everything dude
anything that you want like that's
popular kris jenner that's why
yeah really that's why astrazeneca hit
the [ __ ] because
she was managing astrazeneca first and
then big pharma was like whoever made it
was like i think we're gonna go with
someone else chris jenner's like this is
a [ __ ] mistake yeah and i was like
yeah you know we're good
i'm joking i got it i got it
but that's why you know that's how she
got everyone to do free brand deals for
madeira and pfizer they didn't even know
it
everyone's promoting it after they got
their shot oh yeah that's
absolute mastermind wow yeah that's true
the demilious don't have that yeah
there's no like
real drama besides
um what was it the clip of dixie crying
i saw that on tick tock i didn't see
that like crying her eyes out because
someone told her to kill herself online
or something like that the tick tock was
like yeah i really i also feel bad for
her like i want to cry when i'm watching
this
yeah i guess yeah there's so many ways
to like
like you know
callous your
mental appetite right let's play call of
duty man what play call of duty can you
imagine if dixie demilita responded to
that person and be like you first kill
yourself you first
she can't do that can she
she can't she can that is pretty messed
up i just sorry i just thought of her
dad
every time they're filming him what's
her dad's name i don't know
bruce yeah bruce
that's what we call him yeah
every time they film him he's just like
wildly paranoid of proving that he's not
spending their money
bruce what are you doing no i wasn't i
wasn't college fun it's going they're
building their closet
we didn't ask i just finished
transferring some money to their college
fund
this is the third episode in a row
you've contributed to their college fund
i know i know how to make it well
they're going to go to college at some
point at some point i'm gonna pay for it
well they're paying for it is there
money well is it in a brand new
lamborghini
boom bruce it's for college it's for
college i'm not i'm not going to drive
it i'm not it's like a 10 year old
[ __ ] with
his parents [ __ ]
trying to trying to get them into brand
deals for like way more money
they go to master us to eat and at the
end of the meal he goes i just want to
thank dixie and charlie for dinner
thank you guys i really appreciate it
so i'll let you all know how much i
appreciate
what you do for us
now you didn't have to pay for this
dinner but i'm really glad you did
like dad we didn't what do you mean
i don't even know the pin number to my
bank account
bruce
do we have a second address it's a
college house
it's a it's a house for them to think
about college
dad
dad i'd like to buy a new pair of shoes
yeah
of course the cameras are on you can buy
whatever you want you don't have to
it's not me
go ahead if you want my opinion on the
shoes then i'm there for you
fashion wise you know
here's 15 bucks go to payless no no he
you know he he lets him get the he
doesn't get the dope ass shoes but he's
also in gucci yeah yeah he's in like his
regular ass dad clothes and like those
[ __ ] like you know those velcro strap
super bedazzled shoes he's like what
what she she said i look good in them
my daughter can't buy me a pair of shoes
what dad can't look cool too well come
on oh that's it you know that's aegis
yeah you know that's ageism
picture like dixie and line you know
she's got like maybe a bag or something
like that and the camera like pulls
focus on the dad behind him he's got
like
16 shirts
four blazers three pairs of shoes what
what oh i can't do a little shopping too
my daughter can't buy me some clothes
these are for her graduation ceremony
yeah i'm going to graduate from college
i'm going to need options
i just want to thank dixie and charlie
for taking us shopping today thank you
guys
i bet you they could charge
mid rolls
on tick tocks
it could be a minute long dance in like
20 seconds and hi just want to take a
break
it goes back to the next
20 seconds hi guys before we get to the
end of this dance we just want to give a
quick thanks to casper mattresses yeah
and then they do 19 seconds and right
before they hit the [ __ ] like
penultimate like like whoa or some [ __ ]
one more
one more read for the go what would be
the funniest companies
um
that they could
promote
blue chew
no no
you asked
oh dude hi guys i'm charlie and i'm here
no
oh what dad can have a little
fun hi i'm bruce and i'm here with you
it's [ __ ] bruce hey guys hey guys
bruce demillo here
here to say that my favorite whiskey is
howlerhead whiskey
[Music]
yeah i just want to take a second
interrupt my daughter's really cool
dance and say thank you blue chew for
sponsoring this tick-tock
you know you know you know mrs demilio
loves it when i take the blue chew aisle
man
dick harder than raw pasta let me tell
you
store-bought pasta you know
only difference is mine doesn't break oh
what that can't have a little sex huh
yeah i did
it's like dixie she's about to
do a little dance and then hey guys
sorry to interrupt just want to take a
moment to say thank you horny goat weeds
it's like gas station pills and
absolute degenerative [ __ ]
all you do is take a mouthful of this
stuff and watch this thing rise
we're actually talking about the show
it's a huge break for him i mean his
daughters yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude's cake and uh for his daughters for
his daughter his daughter
yeah he's helping them kick up yeah yeah
death
in a monetary way no we don't actually
we've never
been able to use the bank accounts we
don't have access to them at all
because you know they spend it all on
shoes and notebooks
you know how girls are
right and when they go to college
they can get the rest i can get it
[Laughter]
now i want to watch the show
become a stan yeah
yeah i just want to watch one episode
and be like all right what's going on
here
what is actually happening here
and then you know do some research and
see if we love it stop being haters yeah
we're not being haters
joking a little little sarcasm okay fair